Thank you very much everyone for coming along.
It's a great pleasure to have the opportunity to talk to Google and it's a great
opportunity to have a chance to,
to share some ideas and to get your feedback.
So I'm going to attempt to encapsulate my talk fairly briefly.
I will try to be concise enough that you have lots of,
uh,
lots of opportunity to,
to,
to ask questions.
And also if you feel you want to object,
uh,
you've sense of outrage halfway through and you want to reject as I'm going
along,
that's absolutely fine.
Um,
it's the,
there,
let's make it interactive and so the mind is flat.
That sounds like a very radical claim and it is.
Uh,
but what is it,
what is this claim?
And the,
the intuition will become clearer as we go along.
But the thing I want to,
uh,
to,
to kick against is,
is essentially in the subtitle,
the illusion of mental.
That's so the idea I think a lot of us have is that there's this flow of
thoughts,
conscious experience that that your a and I'm experiencing now that you're
experiencing now.
And that is just one tiny flicker on the surface of a great stream or maybe a
vast river of thoughts,
most of which are hidden mysteriously,
but nonetheless flowing out to the sea.
And this idea that what we consciously experience is just a tiny fraction of the
all the other stuff that our brain is doing,
which is also mysteriously a hidden thought is a very,
very powerful,
a powerful intuition.
Now,
it's a recent intuition.
So if you went back a hundred years or well,
that's 150 years preferred.
Nobody really had this intuition.
The idea then was the mind is that thing which you can experience to the idea
that there could be thoughts that somehow you can't experience with CBE
inherently a bit crazy.
But since,
uh,
since Freud and indeed since I've,
we've understood the brain a lot better,
it becomes much more natural to think,
well,
hang on,
the brain's all doing all kinds of complicated things.
Um,
perhaps my explain have,
you can be explained by all sorts of mysterious machinery is mysterious mental
activity that I'm not aware of now.
I think of course the brain is doing lots of things and I'm not aware of but
they're not faults.
There's something very special,
very particular about the stream of thoughts which makes them very different
from uh,
other things that our brains are doing.
And I want to suggest to you that you're in your natural pre theoretic thought
that no,
actually my mind is this flow,
this stream of conscious experience that is in fact correct.
Now if that's right and we will see a lot more cause he is,
you'll see some reasons to believe this.
It's not just a hazard of coming completely out of nowhere.
I got go see some reasons why you might want to believe this.
If it's right that in fact you can only think one thought at a time and that's
the story one at once no more.
Then we somehow seem to give a good impression that our thoughts are highly
coherent and integrated.
So it's not the case that I just spew out random sense design.
Here's another one in,
here's another in a way that seems totally uncoordinated.
It's almost as if there was a plan behind new sentences.
It's almost as if underneath there's some sort of theory or sort of grand set of
principles,
which I'm drawing on which,
or from which these are these little individual snippets are issuing week.
But what I think that is telling us is we're remarkably good improvisors there's
not the case,
in fact,
that there's a script inside me or a set of principles which generating the
script,
which I'm just playing out.
In fact,
I'm improvising now in telling you my thesis.
Just justice,
your always improvising whenever you're having a conversation with anybody or
doing any social interaction.
And yet of course we are very,
very consummate,
very good.
Improvisors so my imagine for example,
the,
the case of improvisational acting.
You're told now play the role of somebody in their particular situation and
picked her age.
So off you go and you start to think,
well,
yeah,
I think to be saying this,
I seem to be saying that,
oh,
someone's responded.
This is the kind of thing we all do in,
in,
in drama classes.
There's a little interchange occurs.
A story might start to emerge.
Obviously in that case we know that the story did not preexist the character
we're now creating did not preexist either.
The suggestion I have for you is that's what you're doing all the time.
There's not the case that your different from your,
when you're behaving normally to what you're doing when you're doing Improv,
improvisational acting except the part you're playing as your own part
still.
We'll leave those thoughts aside though.
Let's look at some,
uh,
some examples and some illustrations and then we'll come back to the big
picture.
Here is a funny illustration,
which is fun irrespective of anything else I'm going to say,
if you take nothing else away,
this is just a wonderful,
wonderful,
strange illusion.
This is the 12 dot's illusion.
This is invented by a French vision.
Scientists Jack knew and uh,
you'll know they won't notice them.
Were $12 12,
like dots on the screen.
Can you see the wall?
See,
they're all nice and clear.
They're perfectly large enough to see.
I don't,
if any of you are having trouble seeing all of them at once,
say center come and go there.
They,
there's no trickery.
This is the PowerPoint of the normal kind,
that dots,
uh,
a role visible,
perfectly large enough to see if I don't agree it away.
You'd see 12 dots plain as the nose on your face.
And when I put that grade in that location,
if I move the grid to the side,
the troph dots would pop out again.
Um,
if they're in that location though,
strangely they keep popping in and out of existence.
So I find,
for example,
I'm seeing a row of four,
oh no,
no.
Now a different row of,
for,
um,
now I can see too.
Uh,
oh,
hang on.
Yet the Labasa modes appeared.
It was just three for a minute,
and now a fourth one's appeared.
It's all very odd.
What's going on?
Well,
the first thing that's going on is this.
This should give you a sense of the constructive nature of perception.
If you have a secret belief that your perceptual experience is just a reflection
of the world,
then this should make you doubt that because the world is stable here,
but your perception is not stable.
Also,
think about the chunks you're seeing.
Sometimes you see just one dot sometimes to live.
Then there'll be a row.
They're not just picking it,
popping up at random.
You're finding cohesive units.
Things like rose,
things like pears,
things like single dots.
What?
You're not finding his,
oh,
I saw one dot on the top right and Oh,
another one at the bottom left.
Now you don't see that these are organized and only one organization at once.
So what you will not find is,
uh,
your set.
You're fine.
You not find yourself thinking,
oh,
I see a diagonal bar and a,
and a horizontal bar at once.
You can't see that.
You see one bar,
the other stuff is just gone.
You can't see anything else.
But I'm not sure I can see a diagonal.
Oh,
hang halon.
I got,
I got six and one's the,
I got a little um,
Domino's shape chunk.
I don't know if you did.
And You keep looking,
you keep getting different stuff,
but it's always organized.
So what that's implying is that what your personal perception,
your conscious experiences tracking is the organizations you were imposing on
the world is not just the raw stimulus.
It's the organizations.
And we can only impose one organization at once and the brain is continually
fine looking for organizations,
grabbing them and then say,
I've got that one now I throw it away.
Let me find a new one.
I throw that one away.
I find a new one.
If your brain is continually re processing the same material and reorganizing
it.
So as I look at you now,
I'm doing the same thing,
but it's not so obvious to me.
So I can't,
I,
I have a sense of a sea of faces before me.
I have a sense that there are many,
many people in your all visible,
in perfect detail,
in perfect color,
but that can't be right can it?
Because you all know from elementary school biology that I actually,
almost all of your color vision is just in a tiny,
tiny little window about this big.
As I looked through the world,
that's where almost all the color is in the back of my retina.
There's a little bit of color outside,
but not much.
And in fact we know that because there are different cells for picking up color
as I'm sure you will know.
Then there are four,
for example,
detecting change in detecting just a black and white image,
intensity differences and so on.
So most of the color that you can see is in this little window and yet the world
looks colorful also,
as you know perfectly well,
you can only see detail on the fovea,
the,
this,
this little area where you're looking.
Exactly.
So as I look around the world,
through my little,
uh,
little done as it were,
telescope,
um,
where I'm looking is it is in real detail,
but everywhere else isn't.
But that's odd because I seem to see all of you in full color and in full detail
all the time.
And that is an illusion.
What's actually going on is very much what you see here is I'm finding one face.
Then if I another face,
then another face,
but I can't recognize two phases at once.
And in fact there are lovely experiments,
which I'm not going to show you,
but the relevant experiments where you,
um,
you look at where someone's pointing their eye.
But we'll do it.
We'll look at a case with reading in a minute,
not faces.
You look at some where someone's pointing their eye in a crowd of faces and
wherever they're looking,
there's a face,
all the other faces or somehow scrambled.
Just this just mean mashed up by some sort of image processing.
You don't see anything strange.
You just think,
oh yeah,
everyone's there perfectly as normal as you scan what might be a school
photograph.
Everything is scrambled faces except the one you're looking at.
That's fine.
You don't notice anything.
So I have the feeling,
I'm seeing you all in perfect detail and I'm recognizing all these faces and I
recognize it.
See the people who are looking interest in it,
a little less skeptical,
but no,
that's not true at all.
Here's something else which is giving you the sense,
strong sense.
I think that the brain is much more cereal,
much more one step at a time than you might think.
You find one organization in the world,
you,
um,
you impose it organization,
and then you move to the next one,
then you move to the next one.
But you don't do them all at once.
You have the sense that you could,
you're doing them all at once,
but that's an illusion.
So this is a lovely piece of experimental work done by two psychologists of
attention.
Um,
crying and passionate.
They've done lots of great stuff from,
this is just one example.
That big thing is that you can only see one color at a time.
Now you might think,
hang on.
That's just gotta be crazy.
I mean,
look,
here are some grades.
I mean,
I can see more than one color.
I can tell you I z look red and green and yellow and blue.
Conchae uh,
what at first,
before we did the talking to talk through this little,
I'm stimulus in the way they talked about it.
Just note the following.
If I asked you how many colors are there on that screen?
It's quite a hard question.
Four is the answer,
but you have to count.
You don't just see say immediately,
oh yeah,
for if I had four dots on the screen,
you could straight away tell me four dots because you're able to process dots in
parallel.
So four dots for elephants.
For Fish,
you can say straight away,
four actually five you can't.
Five,
six,
seven.
You do start to have to count.
But one,
two,
three or four.
You can process them in parallel.
But colors are not like that.
When you stay a collar,
you've got to think,
okay,
the blue got blue now red,
oh yes.
Uh,
and now are yellow and you've got to count them one after the other.
And it looks like according to their theory,
what you're doing is when you're focusing on red,
yellow has gone,
green has gone.
There's a general sense of colored stuff.
Everything else is colored and varied,
but the only actual color you're seeing is red or yellow or green.
Now,
let me try and convince you that that a bit more persuasively by taking you
through one of the demonstrations.
So here we have these little grids,
and you'll notice that in this grade,
the s,
the grids in fact matching,
they're the same grid.
Notice how an obvious that is.
That is really not obvious that you have to just go through and think,
Oh,
two green squares,
two squares,
oh two green squares to red squares.
You just have to go through step by step and check.
Here's something neat.
Why don't you just think about the reds and check those?
Oh,
you can do that,
can't you?
You can suddenly see,
oh,
we have reds,
this funny shape here.
Look,
there it is.
Yeah,
the reds are the same.
Okay,
and now what about the eyes?
Oh yeah,
the yellows are the same.
And what about the blues?
Oh yeah,
the blues are the same because every time I give you a color,
you can suddenly see a pattern in that color and you can compare.
You can see that pan all at once.
You can see all the green,
you can see all the arrows,
you can see all the blues and you can see they are the same,
but you can't see more than one color.
So if I say,
okay,
what's the,
what shape is created by the Greens?
Easy.
The Greens of this shape,
the yellows are that shape.
But if I say,
oh,
just what shape would be created by the Greens and yellows put together,
no idea possible
one color at a time.
So he,
so the thought here is that when you get to people to do this task,
the best way to do it and the only way they can do it quickly is just to look at
each color,
one after the other.
Similarly with symmetry,
same trick of course.
Similarly with men can rotation.
So let's just do symmetry.
So here we're saying,
oh,
these two things the same.
You can't process color in parallel,
so you don't know.
But what you can do is think,
well,
the yellows are the same and the blues are the same.
And,
and doing it as I say it and say it and the red yet that'll say,
Oh yes,
the Greens are the same or they've had merit mirrors,
I can do that,
but I can't do them all at once.
So
let's have another look at something.
Uh,
back to back to something we were talking about a moment ago.
I mentioned that,
um,
this is going back to the seriality your vision,
not color anymore.
I mentioned that you can have an experiment where we look at say a school
photograph and we mash all the phases except the one you're looking at.
And you notice nothing unusual.
This is the original demonstration of that type of phenomenon,
which was done actually in the mid seventies by Keith Rainer,
very famous psychologist of reading.
And this is an experiment became possible because it was,
it became possible to track people's eyes and create,
change the computer display instantly as they are quite instantly,
but instantly enough as they move their eyes across the screen.
So this is the v the reading version of um,
a fun experiment I mentioned with faces.
So what we have is a sentence,
which in this case is,
it's remarkable how little we actually see at any instant,
even though,
and here's your eye and when they are your eyes,
here we create,
create a little window of 15 letters,
10,
roughly,
um,
to the right five to the left.
If you're reading a language like Hebrew,
which goes the other way,
then you'd have the,
uh,
you,
you'd have the window larger in the other direction towards the left because the
brain is slightly more interested in previewing and looking backwards.
So what you do is you just change all the other letters,
two axes,
and you just allow a little window of lucidity here.
Now as soon as you move your eyes to here,
suddenly the window of lucidity has moved.
And again and again and again and again.
And you can read the sentence quite happily.
You don't realize anything funny.
If you look over the shoulder of the person reading the sentence,
you think,
what's going on?
There's x is everywhere.
Why don't they see it?
But of course they don't see it because exactly where they're looking.
There were proper letters.
It's a very,
very strange,
very,
very strange illusion to be inside.
Another thing you might be interested in as you might think,
yeah,
but Paul is going on when you're moving your eyes.
I mean,
all of these letters are changing and they're changing from letters to exes and
back.
It's a bit odd.
Why didn't I notice that when I moved my eye?
I will ask,
because when you're moving your eye,
you're blind.
You simply can't see anything.
Um,
it's really,
again,
the consciousness falls as completely as I look around the room.
I think,
oh no,
it's all a smooth,
continuous,
continuous perception.
Now I see this.
Now I see that it's flowing effortlessly from one thing to the next.
It's not just to Carto,
but in fact I'm seeing a scrap of information,
then blindness,
then scrapping information,
then blind miss another scrap of information.
And I'm putting all these together to,
to give an extensive of a rich,
continuous conscious experience.
But it's an illusion.
Now I want to switch gears slightly to think about a different way in which,
uh,
our thoughts,
our work very differently from the way we imagine.
So we improvise our way to create a niqab,
the visual world.
We scrambled the other,
a sense of the richness of the vision through these tiny snippets.
And we,
the illusion is so convincing me we think it's real.
But let's now look at something more abstract.
Let's look at a of of emotion.
So here is a famous example by lev cooler chauffeur,
a Russian film director known as the coolest off effect,
much,
um,
talked about by Alfred Hitchcock and very well known in,
in the cinema world.
So this is done with stills,
but in fact it's better done with,
uh,
with moving pictures.
So here is,
um,
I think it's Isaac,
Missouri Kean who's uh,
uh,
one of 'em Cuellar shots.
The actors,
this is going back to the early days of cinema in Russia.
And here he is paired with a,
a,
a sad scene at a,
a child lying in a coffin.
And if you look at this on,
on its own is power.
You think he's looking in a very subtle and kind of a nuanced way,
looking utterly grief stricken.
On the other hand,
if you put in an extra bowl of soup,
he starts to look hungry.
Uh,
and so of course you don't see the effect quite as strongly here because I put
them all together.
Um,
but if you block out the others and just focused on this,
you'll find he's now looking,
he's looking,
kind of interested in this suit cause he's slightly hungry,
but it's very subtle.
Act Two,
he's very,
very,
very understated and Harry is looking somewhat lustful as he looks at this,
this young woman here.
So now you see again,
he's at such a marvelous,
marvelous actor because of his incredible understatement.
Um,
but of course you will have guessed this is the same picture and indeed I think
this is the acute or chefs great insight is that when we're interpreting a face,
we interpreter a lot of the emotion in that face based on the context.
So in fact,
a lot of the secrets,
it at least I think in his view of good acting is not to not to be too
expressive because you want the viewer to impose the appropriate meaning onto
your face.
And if you were to express,
if they can't do that,
you're kind of forcing me or forcing the issue.
But that's interesting because this gives them,
again,
another illusion.
You think when you look around the world that faces,
you think the,
all the activities in the face,
the face just has the look of lawfulness or hunger or our sadness.
But in fact your imposing that you're imposing that because of your wider
understanding of the,
of the situation.
So we're improvising,
not just our,
um,
constructing the world from snippets in a way that fools us.
We're also imposing meaning on snippets here,
faces in a way that forms us.
We think that the meaning is in the face,
but in fact the mania is being imposed from outside.
Here's another similar example.
This is a US senator running for election.
Now if you take this face here and blow it up and cut out everybody else,
this payload looks really very angry.
He does not look happy.
On the other hand,
this is a web.
Jim Webb is Maleah.
Uh,
in the actual election rally,
he's looking triumphant.
Now how odd,
this is the same picture,
but in the context you realize,
yeah,
look off triumphal triumphant delight.
Victory is going to be hours,
whereas here is looking extremely unhappy indeed and frustrated things are
desperate.
Now that's interesting because that's a,
that same insight applies to our interpretation of our own emotions.
So you might think,
well,
if I'm looking at somebody else,
maybe that face is a bit of a cipher and maybe I do have to use other
information to quite work out whether they're angry or they're delighted or
whatever it may be.
Maybe the,
I have to impose extra information,
but of course for myself,
I just know what I'm thinking don't die.
And I think that's a really fundamental illusion because actually this
physiological signals we get from our own bodies are extremely sparse.
And roughly speaking,
and this is two,
two crew.
But not much to crude.
Roughly speaking,
we have two types of signal.
One is saying what's my arousal level?
So saying you know,
I'm really sleepy and bored or I'm kind of excited and the other one is saying
I'm interested and want to approach and engage with this object or personal
thing or of the opposite.
I want to remove myself.
But that's about it,
right?
That's about all you have to go on.
So then you have to take that very minimal physiological signal,
which is like a very,
very uh,
unexpressed your face,
but an internal one.
And you have to think what's going on in the world.
And the,
Oh,
I guess this,
this physiological signal must be telling me I'm angry or it must be telling me
I'm immune to,
it must be telling me something else.
So for physiologically your own physiology is like a really,
really unexpressed,
your face is like the what the example it left cuter shelf gives and to actually
make sense of your own emotions you have to interpret.
So there are lots of lovely experiments are not going to talk about them now,
but there are lots of love to experiments where you can show that people in the
very same physiological state will interpret that state as anger or um,
delight or amusement just based on contextual shifts.
So the idea that the emotions well up from within you is really an illusion.
In fact,
you've got a very thin signal and you're interpreting what an earth must I be
feeling now?
Oh,
I bet it's this telling a story,
improvising your own own emotional thoughts.
Let me give you an example of the improvised nature of choice.
Now this is the famous experiment done by laws hall and Patio Hanson.
So Petta was a postdoc of mine years ago,
but did this experiment before he ever joined my lab and have I have no,
I can take no credit for it,
sadly.
I wish I could.
It's very clever experiment.
So the experiment works like this.
You give people two options and if the task can be anything,
but the most famous original task is which of these faces do you prefer?
So it's done with faces,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't have to be,
I might say about a bit about some of the other options in a moment.
So we sent you say to somebody,
which of these spaces do you prefer?
And they say,
Oh,
I know,
yeah,
it's kind of difficult,
but maybe I sort of slightly prefer that one.
So that's,
that's a slow phase.
So this is step one,
look at his faces.
Step two,
that's my favorite step three.
Oh well have a closer look at that one then.
But step four,
Craig,
I'm given you the wrong one.
Okay.
Did you do this task a lot?
And you only do a trick occasionally.
So in fact,
I subsidy like 32 trials with three tricks.
And if you're wondering,
oh,
I want to do they notice the trick a,
when you asked them,
they don't seem to have noticed the trick,
but be much more cleverly.
Um,
Petta asked People Petron Lars ask people,
uh,
well they say in,
in experiment we just did,
um,
half the half the subjects.
We did some tricks on them and for half we didn't know tricks.
Which one were you?
So this gives them the chance to say,
wow,
I did feel a bit funny about some of them.
I bet you tricked me.
But they don't.
Most people data where about 80% of people don't think there've been trached 20%
deet.
So what's,
what's interesting about the people who've been tricked is that they are now
asked to explain their choice and they do very happily,
they will give an explanation for the thing they did not choose.
And it's a perfectly lucid explanation is just as long as just a fluid is just
like all the other explanations they give.
But it can't be the right,
it can't be anything other than a rationalization.
They can't be doing anything other than improvising because it's the wrong
thing.
So the thought here is that you're an improviser,
you're improvising the visual world,
you're improvising facial expressions,
you're improvising explanations for your choices,
you're rationalizing,
we all sorts of aware that we do a bit of rationalization.
The illusion is thinking.
Yeah,
but sometimes I don't.
Sometimes I just look deep inside to do the actual causes of my own thoughts and
think,
ah,
I know what I really was doing now because I've gone back into,
as it were,
into my own mental history and picked out the real reasons.
But you can't do that.
All you've got is this flow of experience.
All you've got is the sensory experience of the world.
And you've got your own voice and your own sub vocalizations that will
linguistic stuff flowing through your mind.
And you've got some physiological signals that it's,
it you have not got access.
You want to know,
cause I'm privileged key into your own memory.
Here's a lovely experiment,
um,
from 1974 of the ancient experiment,
but a very nice one.
There are many more sense,
but this is the classic,
um,
which gives you a sense of how powerful these effects are.
So this is uh,
an experiment we started with was done on the um,
the campus of the University of British Columbia and on that campus apparently,
and not being on the being to this,
but apparently there was a very high and wobbly bridge like this one.
There's also a low non wobbly bridge.
What you do to in this experiment is you station experiments as attractive
female experimenters at one end of the two bridges may bridge crosses cross now
that interviewed on some fairly pointless questionnaire survey type of study,
uh,
by the,
by the female experiments as then the experimenter says,
oh,
of radical reasons.
If there are any issues raised by this survey,
which there certainly won't be,
um,
you,
you can contact me if you have any problems.
Here's my phone number.
The question is,
does the do the bridge crosses call now the first thing is yes,
they suspiciously do call quite a lot,
which is a bit weird because there's just no issues raised by this survey.
But excitingly,
and this was the prediction,
the bridge crosses who've gone over the High Wobbly Bridge Corp about twice as
often.
Now.
Why is that?
Why is it that a day later or two days later,
they pluck up the courage ne?
They phoned that,
that experiment with some on some pretext.
Why are they doing that?
Just because they walked across a Highbridge bridge.
While the the,
the answer is at least this is the prediction and the explanation in the study.
The answer is when you've just walked across a Highbridge,
you're really full of adrenaline is kind of a scary experience.
Then you meet someone and you're full of adrenaline.
You think,
wow,
you know why?
What's with the adrenaline?
Well,
obviously this person must be just like,
fantastic.
I must say it's totally,
totally did I just totally,
for me,
they did.
There's just this amazing sense of chemistry.
What there is is a huge mass of adrenaline flowing around,
but that's just cause your water costs are being the high bridge.
You,
however,
make the,
the,
as,
as the psychologist called the attribution error,
you don't realize,
oh,
it's the bridges and that of course you think,
well it must be the person and therefore you form this belief that they're
somehow very,
very attractive to you and you really must give them a call.
And I know that as you say,
there are many,
many such such experiments.
But the thought there again is that we have this idea that we have mental dapps
from which things kind of mysteriously appear.
So if you think,
oh,
well,
who am I trying to do?
Well,
as I tried,
I said,
very hard question.
That is,
it's,
you know,
there's all kinds of deep subterranean forces determining this and they just,
but as far as mysteriously,
um,
I just,
you know,
have these strong stable preferences.
They just come from nowhere.
I don't know what they are,
where they come from,
but actually that's a bit of an illusion.
In fact,
a,
you're trying to interpret your own experience as you're going through the
world.
If we tranq you just thought that experience,
then you interpret it wrongly.
Okay.
Now,
why are people not feeble,
um,
highly unstable creatures,
just flitting from one random improvise thoughts for the next,
why are we able to be so high,
highly integrated,
stable characters who are able to lead sort of organized lives?
Well the answer I wanted to give to that is that you should think of your mind
is a bit like a tradition.
So the,
the,
the thought here is that you can only think one thought at a time,
but every thought is shaping the next door and is shaped by the previous
thought.
So you're a bit like a drop of water running down a landscape.
The way that drop of water falls when it rains,
where those droplets fall is determined and when and where they flow is
determined by the landscape that is already there.
But that landscape is itself created by all those previous droplets.
And of course each new droplet.
It just makes a tiny change to the landscape and will therefore affect future
droplets.
So you're a liker,
uh,
you're sort of like landscape created by sort of endless flow of a flow of
water.
Whereas what there isn't in the landscape is a sculptor.
You might think.
Yeah,
but I mean,
you know,
how do these Haniya how do these rocks have such interesting shapes or how,
how has it,
how come the shape to so,
so stable or how come the different kinds of hills have ourselves similar?
Look,
the answer is not that they were created or designed or hair.
There's any,
uh,
as any agency behind them.
They are the process of a long period of one.
Each force,
each little tiny change changing the next change in the next change in the next.
And I think our minds are very similar now and not,
but I also want to give you the sense that the way in which we are change
changed by our experience is incredibly and creative.
So,
so far you might think this is a bit of a negative story.
I thought I could see this whole world.
I thought I could interpret people's faces.
I thought I understood where my,
where my feelings are coming from.
And you're telling me,
I don't,
this sounds while the bad,
but it actually,
I think it's sort of the opposite.
I think in reality we were astonishingly powerful creative machines.
We're able to make sense of the world around us.
We were able to make sense of his facial expressions,
um,
experiences in a way that is extraordinarily labor creative,
inventive.
So I want to give you just a hint of that and cause the,
and then of course we create traditions.
Those traditions are not as some sort of blind copying their,
the traditions that we create in culture,
the arts language that the extraordinarily and indeed science,
the extraordinarily complex,
rich things we can create are all created by gradual incremental,
one fourth of the time growth on this sort of great landscape.
So here's something a bit more about focusing on our,
our creativity.
I'll pull it up from a positive standpoint to here.
Here in this example,
we have the wonderful creativity of perception.
So anyone who thinks,
uh,
in a negative mood or like my,
some people in my family,
he keeps saying things like this.
Well,
I'm just not,
I'm just not creative.
I just,
yeah,
my brain just doesn't work that way.
Think again,
when you look at this amazing image here,
this is a image invented by a Japanese vision scientists,
it Asawa and uh,
of course you can see that it is a sphere,
sort of like a sneaker ball or valuable white Billy Ball type of thing.
Pretty three dimensional.
And you can probably have a sense of though it's an illusion,
but you happen to get the sense that the,
the white and the ball ball area here is just a little brighter than the
surrounding wine.
Of course,
that's not actually true.
What's happening here is that you are taking these pieces,
these exact pieces and turning them into a three dimensional object,
a spiky sphere,
and that is an amazing thing.
So those exact spikes,
those,
those fragments,
when they're organized in a special way,
your brain immediately thinks,
oh,
I didn't see,
I can see a clever way of organizing these.
It's like a puzzle,
but the brain can easily,
easily see the answer.
You can explain why those shapes are the way they are by thinking,
oh yeah,
they're all about the same length spikes,
that clones,
that lack there on a white sphere.
There's all kinds of um,
issues with,
uh,
bits of bits being cut off by the background.
So you can see this spike as well,
the short,
but of course it is because it's pointing away from us and it's occluded by the
billet bit of billiard ball.
And then this one for example,
is coming towards me.
So all of this is perfectly explained by this amazing insight,
but that amazing insight.
It's something your brain just creates in a flash.
So it's not that you all brought your kind of porn or a kind of simple,
uh,
queen show,
which is just being pulled or pushed around by your environment,
your incredibly powerful organizing machine.
And that's,
I think the reason you can only do one thing at a time.
When you're deploying your concentration attention on a particular object you're
able to bring to bear all the other stuff,
you know,
all experience you have of,
um,
in this case,
three dimensional objects can be brought to bear to make sense of this thing.
That's a really hard thing to do and that's why you can only do one at a time.
But don't underestimate the spectacular inventiveness required to do it.
This is the possible number of objects that could under underpin this.
Um,
this,
this set of markings on the page is vast,
but your brain immediately thinks,
oh,
white sphere spikes.
Another illustration is,
uh,
faces.
So here are some found faces,
It just happened to be in new world and now they'll have these faces.
Um,
I think one of the things that's nice about it is first of all,
we immediately see them and they are nothing like faces.
Are they?
I mean,
nothing like the faces that we see every day.
The really have to take a massive creative leap to think,
well you could sort of thing that's sort of a little like an iron that's a
little like an iron as a little like a nose.
And I suppose this is a kind of like a mouth,
not very much.
You have to make an enormous metaphorical jump to get from [inaudible] faces of
actual people to these.
However,
your brain's really good and making creative metaphorical jumps and it does.
The other thing I want to stress here is just how emotional these faces are.
Just as emotional as any lane with with emotion has any um,
real human face.
For example,
there's a kind of anger to this face but also a slight kind of cross eyed sort
of loopiness and you're not quite sure whether to be afraid of this face or,
or to think is slightly ridiculous.
This is an eager to please face it really wants you to like it.
It's trying to look kind of happy,
but it's not.
It feels like I'm trying to hold things together,
but I'm not quite sure I can.
You said cheese grater,
but nonetheless,
that's how it seems.
What about this,
this fellow here that he's kind of a benign face,
little meant drunken,
not it wouldn't want to ask them a difficult question,
is lucky a little bit like he's a little lost,
but nonetheless,
um,
it's,
it's a friendly face.
This poor fellow,
this face here is very,
very concerned.
There's a,
there's a definite sense of fear and confusion.
It doesn't know what's going on,
but it's not good.
Now,
how is that possible?
How is it that we not only see that these are phases,
but we impose such richness on him?
He's the amazing,
of course these faces don't really have it in our life,
but we impose in alive repose,
interpretation on everything,
including each other,
including ourselves.
To finish,
I want to finish with an analogy.
Going back to the,
the metaphor.
The mind is flat and the idea of mental death.
And I want to do that by pointing out some lovely fingers by a,
uh,
an artist in earlier in the middle of the 20th century,
Oscar Reuters filed and a,
he produced what many of you will think of as Asher,
like,
um,
the stimulus if you know,
you know,
and many of you will know Escher but around was around the same time in some
cases before Asher and never all the beautiful in here.
Awesome stamps.
He's a Swede and the Swedish postal service use some of these figures on a
famous set of steps.
Now the nice thing about all of these,
if they are impossible figures,
so if you look at them casually,
you think there's just some blocky three dimensional objects.
If you look more closely,
you start to think,
hmm,
which,
where's the front of my is the back of this thing and the offer further pop
contemplation,
you start to realize these figures actually don't make any sense at all.
So if you look at this one,
for example,
this is a essentially the Penrose triangle as the voice of odd invented the
Penrose triangle around the same time,
um,
as Penrose at Penrose is a original paper completely independently.
Um,
and this one,
so that's that.
So it looks like,
um,
for starting here,
say it looks like we're going back,
that we go back,
we're going space further and further away.
Now let's go down here and we're going back further the further we go.
And then we've gone back and gone back into steps.
We've gone back further into debt and now we're just going vertically as level
in depth and yet we end up where we started.
That's a bit weird.
So it's like I started here,
I went back a bit,
then it went back a bit more and then it went up and I ended up where I start.
That can't be right,
can it?
Um,
and indeed it can't be right.
This is not a possible three dimensional objects.
Uh,
what about this one?
Same sort of thing.
Just trace trace rounds here and you'll find something very old happens as soon
as you start to loop back to where you started with just this.
This just makes no sense.
Similarly,
this one too,
these are very interesting in themselves.
When you think about what they mean for vision,
because that's telling us that we're only able to organize one part of the
stimulus at once.
If we get to organize the whole stimulus,
these are very simple compared to the world around us.
We should immediately say these are impossible.
The light should be,
the alarm bells should be going off because if we could try to integrate this
entire stimulus in one go,
we'd fail because it doesn't have any an interpretation and we think,
oh,
impossible objects,
but in fact we only realize it's an impossible object by going slowly.
We think,
well that'd be,
it makes sense that it makes sense that it makes sense.
Oh,
but hang on.
I'm trying to piece them together.
Oh,
they don't fit together and that it's an effort for slow,
difficult thing.
But so that's interesting in itself because it's an illustration of the
sequential local aspect of vision.
You can't,
you feel you can in some sense see the whole object and you can see that it's
three dimensional.
But that must be an illusion because if you could really see it,
you'd realize it wasn't three dimensional,
but it's an,
it's an interesting illustration in another way.
These are stimulated that look locally lighten.
I have depth.
You look at any piece of them,
perfectly reasonable depth like object.
You try and put the different pieces together.
They do not fit together.
And that is a very interesting analogy for the mind.
In general.
It's if I ask you to explain your actions or justify your beliefs,
you all tell me a story of why did you come up to commute to work.
Oh,
I have a story for that.
Um,
you know,
why did you,
you maybe you take,
take the tube that's a which tube.
Well you have a story for that and I asked you more questions.
That will be more stories.
And more and more and more.
And they all sound very convincing.
I just like eat punch of the image,
which looks three dimensional.
But if I try and get you to put those stories together,
they will not make sense.
And this is the thing that people realize in artificial intelligence in the 70s
and before when they started to try to get knowledge out of experts.
So you'd think the experts now how they do things.
So he just asked them,
well,
you're an expert chess player,
so what did you do in this position and why?
You tell me and expert just less of,
well,
this is obviously the right move.
And um,
uh,
well here's the story.
But then you do it again and again and again.
The story is do not make any sense.
They are not going to hear it.
He didn't story sounds fine,
but they do not fit together because they are rationalizing.
They're not really going in and saying,
Oh yeah,
actually I have this,
um,
and have this deep insight into my mind.
I can just look into,
look at these inner thoughts.
No,
they can't do that.
What they're doing is they're rationalizing and a rationalizing in a very
convincing way.
But all the different bits of rationalization don't fit together.
So I think in fact,
there's a bind,
just flat cover,
uh,
has,
exactly this quality,
uh,
has,
has the look of a three dimensional object.
But it isn't.
And this is to illustrate the idea that actually your mind itself as you
traditionally conceive it as we traditionally conceive ourselves is itself an
impossible object.
We imagine that I don't just have one or two beliefs that I've just thought of
at the moment.
Uh,
each,
each belief is justified by huge networker bleed.
It just goes on forever.
And my motives,
I can think of one or two,
but there must be many,
many of them.
And they themselves were all carefully into linkedin and intertwined.
But in fact,
as you students,
you start to explore that.
And that's quite a big theme of it.
But which I haven't really talked about today.
If you soon as you try to articulate and explore the connections between all
those different snippets of information,
snippets of beliefs,
snippets and motivation,
if they do not fit together,
in fact your mind is impossible object and just the same sense as a rotor,
Vod or ashes,
strange,
impossible objects.
So I think the,
the take home message is that we are amazingly any creative stupendously free,
uh,
improvisers and each improvisation has done at the,
on the basis of the last improvisation and were so convincing that we think
there's a script he said like improvising improvisational actors who are so
good.
You Think,
oh,
you need to learn that haven't you?
Somebody wrote that script for your,
you're reading it,
but there is no skip.
They are improvising and were so fluent,
were so good that we don't realize.
In fact,
we're making it up as we go along.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
we do time for questions.
Please raise your house.
So I don't really know how this is different from exactly what fried said.
I mean there we have a set of illusions,
um,
you know,
slips of the tongue and whatever that had,
that are created by the dynamics of improvisation.
You've,
you created this kind of strange thing called descript.
Everybody knows it's not a script actually.
There's some internal generative processes which produce,
um,
uh,
perceptions and these can be more or less integrated a different people.
So I just want to know exactly,
you know,
it seems as if Freud was here,
uh,
if Freud was,
he wouldn't have any problem with anything you were saying.
So I can you just deal with the deathly blowed the whole thing?
Yeah.
I,
I'd like to think Floyd words.
I'd be delighted if we turned out to agree,
but I think he wouldn't because for Freud's,
the,
the conscious is only a tiny fragments of thought.
So too,
I would agree that there's a lot of stuff.
The brain's doing a lot of stuff we're not conscious of.
In fact,
everything.
Pretty much.
The only thing is we are conscious of and are essentially a sensory experiences.
And I would include in that
imagery and also language.
But essentially we're only conscious of very narrow sensory experiences.
That's it.
But I think for Freud he'd say,
no,
that's right.
You're,
you're hungry.
The,
the,
those are the thoughts you're conscious of.
But there are other things which are a bit like that.
They're just hidden.
So there's something else,
which is,
it'd be,
like Freud would say,
I think there's an iceberg and you can,
there's a tip of the iceberg,
which is the conscious thoughts.
And then below that,
there are all kinds of other con unconscious processes.
Now I want to say,
no,
that's an iceberg metaphor is,
is a mistake.
There's the,
the,
the things that as it were,
a visible or nothing like the things that are invisible.
And so what,
what's invisible is essentially the vast tradition of vast history of previous
thoughts you've had and what you're doing when you're coping with the current
situation is your drawing on all those past experiences of previous situations.
You're in all actually there's no,
as it were,
underlying generative mechanism.
You can,
you can,
uh,
refer to all you've got is as it were,
lateral connections between,
between,
uh,
one thought and the next.
So it's a disagreement about the content of that,
the nature of the things underneath.
Because I suppose when you're describing those illusions to us,
what you're doing is equivalent to a kind of therapy in,
in,
in making conscious,
into thoughts,
the processes that resulted in that illusion.
Yes.
Although I,
that's absolutely right.
But the way I would think of it is that we think of it as a process where
something that was previous to unconscious is now con conscious.
But I think that's,
it sounds by mistake.
I think the,
it's not that there was a fault,
which I wasn't aware of and now I am aware of it.
It's empty that the mechanisms are completely and utterly,
utterly different.
Um,
so for example,
if you think about the patterns in language forever,
they're very,
very complicated.
We learn,
it appears in a very exemplar based way.
So I hear different phrases,
I generalize from those phrases.
I grabbed the assembler language as a child.
And that language has all kinds of complicated patterns.
And as a linguist you might say,
Oh look,
you,
you didn't know about this complicated rule or pattern,
did you?
Um,
and the answer is absolutely not.
The explicit task of finding patterns in language is a total mystery to me,
but I think what's going on there is not that you're making it explicit to be
something that I sort of knew.
It's just that I've learned all these fragments and these fragments create this
pattern and I never do nothing about the pattern.
Only only knew about the fragments,
the things I know about or things that are always either that conscious now will
they were so yes,
it's a deal.
It's a disagreement about it as it were,
what the substrate is.
Yeah.
This is an important question.
That's too bad.
Especially when you argue with Saquon list,
would would tread say,
yeah,
I agree completely with their landscape image,
except that the landscape,
he's moving by itself.
Your is changing.
We had the drops.
Yes.
I think that's probably right actually.
So I'm very much hostile to the idea,
which I think there's not much experimental evidence that the landscape is
moving by itself.
Um,
I mean,
in fact the brain,
when you're focusing on a particular task,
your entire brain witness is too extreme,
but large areas of your brain are really focused on whatever that task is.
So if you're,
you're reading word,
you're listening to a piece of music.
If you're locked on to that stimulus,
we've vast tracks of your brain will be active in,
in locking on to that stimulus.
Now of course there's lots of autonomous stuff going on.
You're still breathing is not falling over.
There's all kinds of things which are actually relatively separable from,
from general cognition,
but high level cognition,
the ability to freely,
um,
it's our 10 to one thing and then the next seems to be roughly sequential and
whatever it's locking onto it that at any given moment is roughly obliterating
the possibility of locking onto anything else.
So I think that's exactly right.
I think the,
uh,
the,
um,
the uh,
at least,
uh,
port Pirie illusion we have is that as well as the conscious processing that's
going on my brain just doing all kinds of secret posting in the background.
Just thinking about the kinds of things I normally think about,
but thinking about him in the background.
Whereas I think the brain is thinking about lots of other things,
but they're things like not falling over.
They're very different in character
and different sorts of question.
Um,
one characteristic of many autistic people is that they find it difficult to
infer emotional from faces.
What is your theory to say about that?
That is a very interesting question.
I mean,
I don't have any specialized knowledge here,
but I do think it's possible at least it's interesting to imagine that perhaps
the big problem is the contextual,
uh,
integration of context,
which I think,
I know some theories of,
of autism do focus on the idea that I'm generally trying to create her holds out
of many individual parts is quite difficult and there's a tendency to focus if
you have autism on,
on parts and analyze those parts very in detail rather than be able to
integrate.
So it could be at least one part of the story could be that I'm trying to
interpret faces requires this Wharton,
this integration,
not just the view of the visual stimulus,
but actually all of this surrounding surrounding stimulus,
which may be difficult to do.
Your,
some of your definitions seem a bit too otologist.
So you say you can only,
there's only conscious thoughts,
but you define thoughts as things which are conscious and you say you can only
do one thing at once.
But say my hobby is dancing and while dancing with a partner,
I can hold a conversation with her and you would say,
oh you only,
the only thing you're actually doing is the conversation and the dancing doesn't
counters a thing because you're doing it at the same time.
So it feels a bit,
yeah,
no,
you let me,
let me,
let me just make that a bit more precise.
So,
so the,
the thing that the right,
the more correct story,
but a bit more complicated story would be to say any bit of brain I would argue
can only do one thing at a time.
So you've got complicated set of networks in your brain.
If those,
if those network though each network and only do one thing at a time.
Now if it's the case that you can take on two tasks,
which as it happens,
do not use overlapping networks,
then you're fine.
Now if you're beginning dancing,
this is not the case because there's so much top down control,
which was required to keep me,
keep me doing the right moves in right order.
Then there's a lot of overlap between this,
the same top down mechanisms that you need to run a conversation but but so for,
for,
for too complicated tasks you're done for but for things that you've done a lot,
some,
some tasks are,
are um,
are,
are possible to,
to run in parallel.
Now an example I talked about in the book is very,
very nice example of touch typing and sight reading.
So you get 'em so you get,
is that right?
Yeah,
no sight,
sight,
reading,
sight reading and shadowing.
That's the one I want to focus on.
So here you are as a very experienced pianist,
your site or any piece of music and also you're hearing in your ear a voice and
you just have to say what the voice is saying and wonderfully you can do that.
I not,
if you're not a very good pianist you're totally fail.
But if you're a good pianist,
the sight reading is relatively autonomous process.
This,
the re re re,
re generating what you're hearing is relative to autonomous process.
It wouldn't be if it was in that language you weren't very familiar with,
that will become a very hard process.
So it has to be strong.
You automated processes and,
and so yes,
there are a few examples where you can really cleanly see that the brain
networks are not overlapping and then we're fine.
But that's really the exception.
But they're very important exception.
Very interesting assumptions are,
for example,
I should say,
driving is actually not one of these exceptions.
So if you happen to think as I'm driving along,
um,
I could have a chat on my,
my,
my hands free phone with no interference.
You'd be absolutely wrongness lovely experiments showing it.
Um,
even if you have to do the most trivial auditory task,
monitor some auditory signal that really screws up your ability to break,
for example.
So that our intuitions about what we can automate and what we can do separately
is not very,
not very good.
Often we're actually swapping from task to task very quickly.
My understanding is that sleep is used for the organization and memories.
So how does that fit until theory?
Yeah.
So I think it's not under,
it's not very well understood how sleep plays a role,
but it does seem to play an important role.
And I suppose this account can deal with that to the extent that that process is
mediated by dreaming,
dreaming,
dreaming.
You are just replaying and this is the whole replay theory.
You get a lot in neuroscience.
So the idea is that you're doing something a bit like being awake,
um,
and your doing more flip preconscious flow of experience and that is allowing
you to reprogram the system.
The,
if it's the case since.
So what,
what does this approach rules out is the idea.
There's some other process which is not going through the processes essentially
of conscious experience,
which may be too strong.
I mean,
I'm not,
this is a particularly strong view.
I think it's roughly right.
There might be some,
some processes which,
uh,
which are,
which are going on in a completely nonconscious level that,
but I'm willing to keep going.
We going with the strongest possible stolons until absolutely forced not to,
but,
but I think that's,
I think as broadly,
right.
For example,
if you give people problems to solve and you've,
they sleep on them,
yes,
they're slightly quicker than if they hadn't slept on them to solve them when
need to ask them again,
and that seems to be pretty much entirely explained by the fact that they've
forgotten the era four ways they started,
tried to solve them the first time.
So I give you a problem.
You Think,
Oh,
is it?
Let this you're wrong.
If you,
if you're right,
you solve it,
but if you do,
if you're wrong,
you get it,
you,
you come draw up the wrong mental set the wrong interpretation of the problem.
You get stuck.
Then you go to sleep.
You've forgotten now and you're quick,
but there's seems to be no evidence that you were solving the problem in your
sleep.
It's a really active reprocessing and though we intuitively feel we're doing
that from time to time is almost certainly an illusion.
I can remember that about this.
I just wanted to make a remark.
Remember that Michelle is Uva.
I think the discover of rim sleeping cats w suggested that you make of the dream
as you re recall it in fact,
you don't recall the dreams.
You just make it happen.
So that kind of goes in your,
uh,
we'd let you were saying,
but my question was about thought with that language and Musky like
mathematicians,
like at [inaudible] and how they solve a problem by claiming a train.
What you make of that.
Yeah,
I mean I think that's very,
very interesting.
So one person had discussed in the book is Pine Care,
right?
Who is,
yeah,
this phenomenal geometric genius who was able to vote by in according to his own
description in a very geometrical way to solve very deep problems and then sort
of write down the symbols later.
And I think the,
the fact that he was experiencing this imagistic Lee is not a tall,
um,
and that's what he's conscious of that we were always conscious of is the,
is the,
is a visual traces of the thoughts.
Um,
but all you're ever conscious I think is the,
is the,
is the sensory now clearly it must be that these,
these thoughts as he's generating them and that being,
I think created one by one in the moment is not the reading off from something
that in a mathematical textbook.
Um,
but he's creating these thoughts one in the moment,
but all he's actually able to consciously report about is these kinds of images
stick traces.
They said [inaudible] all you're conscious of it is the surface of your
thoughts.
Not Nothing,
nothing beyond that.
But I do think the fact that people have a very strong sense of imagery being
important in mathematics is absolutely very important.
Anything that's,
uh,
that's,
epar phenomenon,
I think it's really,
well,
probably rather crucial.
Okay.
Not necessarily.
I am,
however,
a great believer in the utility of the idea of free will.
So this is not,
it's not an,
it's not,
I completely believe in a deterministic world or we're just having to stick up
to quantum mechanical effects.
But some,
I think the intuition we have of having of our sales being free is that we have
the ability to create,
um,
the,
ah,
the interpretation of the presence and interpretation of what we should do in
freshly in the moment.
And I think that's absolutely right.
So you could have a story which says,
well,
you're,
you're kind of in a behaviorist,
a nightmare.
You've,
you've,
you've laid down various associations and a stimulus comes along and he just
find yourself on a unavoidably charging towards the fridge and eating cheese or
whatever because of that bell and it's no stopping it.
That would be a very different story.
I think we're extraordinarily clever,
creative,
sort of metaphorical creatures who are able to be very flexible in our behavior.
Now you might say,
well,
but at base it's all determined.
It isn't it really.
Um,
and I think the answer to that is,
is it an answer?
Quine I think probably goes back beer for four that said,
the philosopher Queen has this nice comment that that says,
well of course free will's about being free to do as you will.
It's not about being,
it's one about being free to will as you will.
So there's something kind of in here any bonkers about that idea.
So these,
those big free is to have the ability to,
to think flexibly,
decide what you want to do and to do it.
Not being free is being controlled by impulses that continually takeover and
force you down channels you didn't want to go down.
So that's a sort of soft science.
He not deep philosophical,
deep a solution,
but I,
yeah,
I like the idea of free will.
Um,
I think,
I think it's actually a deep and meaningful intuition about this and I think it
distinguishes from lots of other,
um,
other
inches.
It seems common to get insights that appear fairly fully formed.
Say when all showing or some discounts the blue,
how might that kind of thing like be explained?
Yeah.
Well,
I think there's quite a lot of work on this in the world of problem solving
research and what seems to be going on is that your,
you've got a lot of prior thinking then you have a clue that you hadn't thought
of before or a little insights you think,
ah,
maybe maybe this'll work and mostly it doesn't.
So that the illusion is that when,
when it does work you think,
oh yeah,
the whole thing is clear to me now because now I see roughly how it's going to
go and look.
Oh I'm putting the pieces in.
Oh no,
they all fit.
I sort of saw that all along.
I think that's a sort of retrospective Craig,
because we all equally and I said you have this a lot.
You probably all do you have a problem,
you think,
Oh I think this is it.
Um,
and in fact it isn't.
Now you try to put the pieces together.
Nope,
no that doesn't work.
Okay,
let's do it again and wait.
But when it does work you have the feeling that Oh yeah,
why I did see there correctly all the pieces fitting together.
Cause they it.
Um,
but I think actually that's,
that's a,
that's a bit of a bit of an illusion.
So there's an awful lots of a lot of artists and scientists have the,
the um,
uh,
the story about saying,
Oh,
and in a single moment I suddenly vividly completely saw the entire score of my
Sonata.
But when on press being pressed is how well he did actually take me like two
weeks to write it.
You know,
a lot of hard thinking of,
I sort of saw how it was generally going and I think that sense of,
I sort of see the whole eight all clear to me now is something that is a,
there's a slight selection bias there.
Um,
however,
of course it's still true that sometimes you do have organizing thoughts which
allow you to see something in a more abstract way,
which it does actually give you the structure which will help everything fit
together.
But there you're thinking it'd be like seeing a phage and thinking,
I'm not just seeing the face.
I'm also seeing the eyes and the eyelids and the pupils and you're not right.
When you're seeing the face,
you're seeing the face,
you look at the eye,
you're not seeing the face it.
So we have the illusion.
When you see it,
or as you're looking at a whole body,
you really aren't in a very real sense seeing the face anymore.
But we have the illusion.
If I have an abstract high level thought and kind of seeing,
grasping all the internal structure,
that's a bit of a fiction.
We are out of time.
I'm just passionately,
so thank you again.
[inaudible].